have you considered just making the film
on your own because I have ideas that
you want and you don't want the studio
or whomever change I have I have
actually had a guy approached me I grew
up with a really rich guy and his family
his dad was a senator and you know it's
all money South money cotton money yeah
and it's funny because they they're his
family owned my family back in the day
we never even knew it growing up
together the only real estate company
they're huge anyway he came to me and
asked me if I wanted to make it but he
wanted to control everything that's kind
of person is and I'm not really big on
and he was I was all about the dollar
signs you know and I'm not rich yeah you
know but it's not about the money for me
if that'd been one of my other projects
maybe but not this one yeah I'm just way
too passionate about this you know so he
wanted to commercialize it and I'm not
really big on that so yeah we still talk
so so that works so this was near where
you grew up yes yes yes it's Columbia
South Carolina and Florence Columbia I
worked in mostly I was the arbitrator of
the year for one year and I had to go to
all the other arbitrator's in the 16th
circuits and I had to supervise them for
that one year and so I saw stuff all
over and you know the misconception is
crime happens just in big cities but
little cities I you know some of the
worst crime I've seen has been in small
towns and I think one of the reasons is
because kids are bored they have nothing
No Boys and Girls Clubs there you know
then you got Barney Fife as the sheriff
and his sidekick you know and these kids
know that and gangs have taken over
small-town America like crazy at least
in our safe so yeah I've seen seen a
whole lot in those towns yeah so what
kind of notes have you gotten aside from
making it more commercialized or keeping
it one theme yeah what are their notes
have you gotten about
your work I've actually gotten really
it's funny because I pitched earlier to
a company that I pitched on virtual
pitch fest and if you've heard him I
pitched on that site and the guy said
well we're going to say no now but if
you add this maybe we'll say yes so I
noticed he was here and it's okay well
I'm going to take him at his word you
know and does so I added those two
elements he suggested I added more of a
political element and a community-based
element and so when I sat down with him
a while ago I said hey you're the guy
that told me to do this you know what I
showed on the pitch I actually ran it
off you know from virtual pitch fest he
said oh yeah I remember writing that and
I said well that made it a better piece
and so he was you know flattered by that
of course but he said dude I got to see
it you know but I wanted to want him to
see that you know you're the one that
told me you do this you can't say no now
no so he he actually said okay you're
right I can't say no so he got
screenplay I brought it with me in a
gave it to him yeah so some updo
you